governors with states with stay-at-home
orders say they are eager to lift them
as well but not until there's enough
testing to know if it's safe they've
been looking for federal leadership on
that issue we do Jang is at the White
House for us with the latest tensions
between states and the president we
should good morning what are you
learning good morning Tony as the
administration continues to face
backlash for not having a national
testing strategy vice president Mike
Pence has a call scheduled for later
today with all the governor's to talk
about their plans and supplies public
health experts say testing would have to
at least triple the current rate before
the country can open safely the
governor's wanted to have total control
over the opening of their states but now
they want to have us the federal
government do the testing president
Trump said it was not the responsibility
of the federal government to conduct
tests testing is is local you can't have
it both ways testing is a local thing
but governors say they need the
administration's help I can't do an
international supply chain and that's
where the federal government has to help
because no state can do that Maryland's
Republican governor Larry Hogan says
there's simply a shortage of equipment
try to push this off to say that the
governors have plenty of testing and
they should just get to work on testing
somehow we aren't doing our job it's
just absolutely false
dr. Deborah Burke says coronavirus test
data is crucial and pointed to what
Florida has posted on its Public Health
website they've been able to show their
community's cases and TAS
district-by-district county by county
zip code by zip code that's the kind of
knowledge we empower we need to put into
the hands of American people after weeks
of calls from state and local officials
the President on Sunday announced he
would use the defense production act to
force companies to make more swabs
essential parts and testing kits and in
short supply this is what it's about but
other resources are lacking too like
the agents a critical chemical to
complete the testing process
we're fighting a biological war we've
been asked by the way as governors to
fight that war without the supplies we
need despite calls for help from
officials on the ground mr. Trump pushed
back reagents and swabs are so easy to
get of course the other big component to
this pandemic is the economic fallout
later today lawmakers are expected to
announce a deal that would allocate
another three hundred billion dollars to
small businesses after the first round
of aid for more than that amount ran out
in just two weeks plus an additional 100
billion dollars is expected to go to
hospitals and testing Yale we should
thank you very much